we learned earlier this week that
conspiracy theories can have real-world
implications beyond just the dark
corners of the internet with the entire
pizza gate theory earlier this week we
actually had a guy show up at comet ping
pong in Washington DC to quote self
investigate the pizza gate conspiracy
theory and actually discharged his gun
is ar-15 assault style rifle there's a
popular conspiracy theory that we
haven't talked that much about lately
that's the Sandy Hook was a hoax
conspiracy theory relating of course to
the Sandy Hook massacre in Newtown
Connecticut on December 14th of 2012 one
of the worst mass shootings in US
history and the conspiracy theory
alleges that it was all staged the
victims were crisis actors it was all a
false flag and this now has led to
real-world consequences because of 57
year old Florida woman stories that
start with Florida woman or Florida man
they often go in a pretty dark direction
a 57 year old Florida woman has been
charged with threatening to kill the
parent of a victim of the Sandy Hook
elementary school shooting massacre
because the woman believes that the
shootings never happened this is Lucy
Richards she's accused of sending
several threatening text messages to the
child's parents saying you gonna die
death is coming to you real soon
according to the federal indictment that
is now public the US Attorney's Office
said Richards is belief that the school
shooting was a hoax and never happened
motivated her to make the charged
threats she was arrested a few days ago
charged with four counts of transmitting
threats in interstate commerce and if
she's convicted she could face up to 20
years in prison I actually don't even
understand the logic even if you thought
the attack was fake why would you kill
one of the parents of the kids I just
don't understand how you even get to
that maybe because they were trying to
pull the wool over everyone's eyes and
the whole conspiracy theory makes no
sense because no effective gun
legislation came out of the Sandy Hook
shooting they tried to pass even the
minimal gun legislation but couldn't do
it I I was thinking about that Rachel
where the what was
the Preet what was the the motive for
this conspiracy theory according to the
conspiracy theorists it was Obama is
setting up false flag attacks involving
guns so that then Obama or the
government or the Illuminati or the New
World Order or whoever it is they can
confiscate guns and pass gun bans it's
been four years since the shooting
Rachel
President Obama is days from leaving
office
there have been no massive gun
confiscations the attempt to pass but
the the background check bill which most
Americans agree with didn't even happen
and there are more guns floating around
than ever so even the motive that was
presented it didn't happen it was a
major failure if you believe it it
definitely was that that part is quite
puzzling to me she's incredibly eloquent
but it's interesting because who that
the man who was actually threatened has
been threatened many times before and
there was a professor I think it was
from a university in Florida also who
said that everything was a hoax and then
he was actually fired and he was saying
this is an infringement on my free
speech and said no your free speech is
protected but your jobs not yes right
there were consequences to him spreading
conspiracies conspiracy theories in
class and using that as a stage for his
nutter ii if these supposed
false flag attacks are the pretext to do
gun control then they have failed
miserably not just with this particular
conspiracy theory pat but just more
broadly thinking about it as well and
then there's people like alex jones in
the forefront of this whole conspiracy
theory and to some extent this blood
would have been on his hands right and i
guess
he claims to have spoken with
president-elect donald trump in the past
few days it is very very scary that
conspiracies conspiracist
in chief Alex Jones is claiming to be in
touch with the president-elect and we've
talked before about why these conspiracy
theories are appealing and I think at
its core it's the idea that for some
people the reality that we can't control
everything and sometimes horrible things
happen that are out of our control we
can do whatever we want to try to be
vigilant and stay safe etc but sometimes
really bad things happen that is scarier
to many people than the idea that
this was a staged attack or that someone
planned it it's the fear of the
out-of-control and unknown that I think
underlies why some of these conspiracy
theories pick up steam Rachel and for me
I'd rather live in a world where I know
the truth rather than I think that
everything was a staged plan for optics
and to achieve some political goal but
for some people it's almost more
comforting to think this wasn't a random
event someone planned this and here's
the explanation as to why that's true
and I in I don't know I feel like a lot
of large massacres there's usually a
small margin to believe that there is a
conspiracy theory and when they do crop
up it seems like a lot of the people who
are perpetrating them are slightly
deranged well yeah I mean sometimes when
you look at someone who's willing to
show up at a pizza shop with an ar-15
rifle because of something that was
posted to an internet message board
I don't know that you're necessarily
completely of sound mind if that's even
something that you're willing to do so
real-world consequences for the pizza
gate conspiracy theory real-world
consequences for the Sandy Hook was a
staged hoax conspiracy theory this stuff
matters and I'm not gonna rehash my
little rant about stochastic terrorism
today but google that and check out the
clips that I've done about that